So, welcome everybody.
Um
very happy to um
uh talk today about uh generalist uh
robot policies. Um also, um this is uh a
topic where I have also myself done a
bit of research over the last years.
Um so, very uh excited to share um some
insights here and also uh hopefully um
some lessons that uh we've learned along
the way uh that might be useful for you
uh now that you're uh training yourself
like via laces and so forth for your uh
group projects.
So,
um if you remember, we already have
covered um some um very impactful work
in uh robot learning um from uh the last
few years uh like ACT or diffusion
policies um um that really excel at um
doing this like dexterous tasks and uh
learning uh handling like multimodal
behaviors really well. Um and um you can
see like the the demos are really,
really impressive, very dexterous, uh
high-frequency control.
Um however, uh these methods um as we as
we have seen in the past, they are um
really well suited um to fit like
single-task policies. So, it's kind of
like more specialist um um models. Um
and um are a little bit harder um to
kind of scale to uh train more
generalist um
multi-embodiment
uh robot policies. Um like typically
here, um you would need to retrain like
your policy often for uh like new uh
robot policy uh robot embodiments or new
tasks and so forth.
Um and so, what's the goal? Like um the
North Star um of the robot learning
community uh is really to build
generalist robot policies that can
control many robots
uh with a single model in many
environments and perform also many tasks
while working with and alongside humans,
right?
And so this is kind of our quest
towards, let's say, the the holy grail
in robot learning
and it comes with many questions such as
where do we get the data from to train
these models or
how can we model like very large-scale,
very heterogeneous data distributions,
how can we generalize these
policies to
unstructured um
environments in the real world and so
forth, right? And so the our goal is
really to enable kind of this future
where um in which you can download your
favorite robot brain online and then
out-of-the-box your robot should start
showing reasonable or ideally
intelligent behavior
in a useful manner for your particular
robot, right?
Um of course this is very much inspired
from advances that we've seen in the NLP
and computer vision communities
that we already have kind of covered in
the lecture.
Um
and [clears throat]
as you know, the work to kind of like
canonical workflow workflow to to
develop these these models, these
foundation models in NLP are that they
train on like a large diverse data set
containing not just a single task but
many many different tasks,
right? So it could be like code
completion, language translation uh
question answering and so forth.
And
then we have seen that typically
these models
outperform the
behavior of kind of more um
single like specialist models that are
like more tailored towards doing one
specific task. Right? And this is let's
say this this this paradigm shift that
we have seen where large models trained
on diverse data sets
will typically surpass more specialist
models
that we maybe like in the past years
were developing for different tasks like
object detection, language translation,
image captioning and so forth. Right?
And so this are
so this are these foundation models like
the LLMs nowadays and
in robot learning our goal is to kind of
we would like to see the the same
benefits and behaviors for robotics too.
Right?
So let's talk about what are some of the
key ingredients that
we need in order to develop such
generalist robot policies and what what
are some of the key differences
and challenges in applying
the same recipes that have worked in NLP
and vision to robotics.
So to start with kind of the obvious the
first obvious thing that you'll notice
is that
>> [clears throat]
>> in robotics we don't have the luxury of
like really large scale
robot data sets that
are comparable in size to the ones that
you will find
in NLP and
vision that are used for frontier
modeling nowadays.
Because robot data is is scarce and
expensive and you know now that you
probably have started collecting your
first teleop
demos with the with your SR101 like you
can imagine like how hard it is to
you know collect these demonstrations to
reach the same magnitude of like a
frontier model.
Um
And so additionally
um
uh, there is also a difference in that,
um, in terms of how to model this data,
right? So, um, robot data is is very,
uh, multimodal, um, and very
heterogeneous, right? Uh, so instead of
just training on natural language or or
even just like language and vision, um,
we have like multiple sensing modalities
with with, uh, with robots,
um, that, um, we need for the robots to
be able to interact, uh, with the real
world because interacting is in the real
world, as you know, is like a
multi-sensory experience, right? Um,
[snorts]
and uh, so basically every each robot
embodiment has different observation and
action spaces. So, it's really very
heterogeneous.
Um, additionally, we also typically want
to do, um, real-time control with our
robots.
Um, so we don't, um,
want to send a query to ChatGPT and like
wait a minute for its API to, uh, return
a response that tells us how, uh, the
next action for our robot should be,
right?
>> [snorts]
>> Um,
so, um, and finally,
uh, we also,
uh, as we scale the the capabilities of
our generalist robot policies
uh, that can now not only do like a
single task, but many tasks, maybe even
with many different environments, um,
you can think that the cost for
evaluating these models like increases
like dramatically, right? Um, so we need
also ways of doing like more, um,
scalable evaluations or better better
ways of doing evaluations.
And so we'll talk a little bit about,
um, these three ingredients in today's
lecture.
So, let's start with the data. Where do
we get this from? Because, um,
uh, as as you know, like no matter, uh,
what the embodiment is, um, like
it's it's really expensive to
teleoperate a robot um, uh, uh, and you
know for each and each and every new
task that you want to teach your model
um
and I can talk from experience here here
on the left you can see how I'm like
teleoperating to collect some data with
the Franka robot
in the setup I did for my PhD.
And so it's really costly
to collect data.
And so the key idea that enabled the
first versions of generous broad
policies was to leverage existing
sources of data.
So in general
there had been some previous efforts
in the community to collect like some
data sets but
usually not in a way that enabled
co-training between them. And so kind of
the
the key idea here is that
in general like
no matter
what your research is about every
robotic labs in the world collects some
sort of data, right? Like maybe like
your lab focuses on I don't know like
touch sensing and you collect like some
teleop data with like tactile sensors or
something.
And it's usually like very small scale
data to support like your research and
and your papers and that's why often
like we don't think of putting it online
or you know we think it might not be
interesting for others, right? But it in
essence there is a lot of existing robot
data in the world. And so
when I was wrapping up my PhD I was able
to collaborate with Google on this
project called the Open Ex Embodiment
data set where we essentially
um
went and asked all our friends in
different labs around the world if they
had any available robot data and then we
aggregated all of that put it into a
common format that allowed co-training
on it.
Um, and that's basically what we did.
Um, and we ended up with
over a million of real robot episodes,
which was substantially
more than any previous
like robot data set effort up to that
point.
Um, and this was not just like a single
robot embodiment, but
many different like over 20 different
robot embodiments. Um,
and as you can see like really like like
a lot of labs around the world
participated in this this effort.
And regarding the results of this
project, this was really the first time
where we saw sparks that is of a single
model trained on all these multiple
robot data sets surpassing the best
previous method that was tailored for a
particular
setup.
Um, and so here these are kind of the
main results and you can see
I for example contributed continuous
evaluations during the model development
with the robot setup
that I built during my PhD in Germany,
which you can see on the top.
And so
um, this paper
has been quite impactful because it
allowed now algorithmic progress on the
modeling side of generalist robot
policies
by making it possible to train on
over a million of diverse cross embodied
robot trajectories for the first time.
And many of the works I will present
today or I will
will build up upon this data set or will
use this data set as their foundation.
Okay. Um, so
I have talked about where we can for
example
get the data to train generalist robot
policies.
And now the second question is how can
we model um this data? Um,
right? Uh, what can we do with this
data?
Uh, because of course this is easier
said than done, right? Uh, as I already
mentioned um
a few slides ago, um in general like
robots are very very heterogeneous. They
have uh different task specifications,
different types of sensors,
uh different numbers of cameras, like
maybe one robot has a single camera,
another has like three or four, um
different very different action spaces,
and figuring out how to share
information and knowledge across robots
and um
uh
uh that looks so different uh makes this
a very uh challenging problem.
So, let's start with a basic example.
When we typically train um a robot
policy, um the as you already have seen
in the exercises, uh the model will take
as an input um a current observation,
uh an image, and a task uh description,
um nowadays often in in natural
language, right? And then the model will
predict like a sequence of of
end-effector uh poses, uh let's say, uh
to achieve um the goal of this uh tasks,
right? And now our premise is that uh we
want to um uh
uh fit uh like a generous robot policy
uh on a very large diverse heterogeneous
um
uh data set.
And now if we um uh squint a bit and we
um we replace the robot image with a
more regular internet image, and now we
replace the instruction with um let's
say uh a caption of um captioning the
scene, right? Um,
and then, you know, like the model
answers like, "Oh, like the picture
shows the Statue of Liberty" or
something.
Um, this starts to look quite familiar
uh because essentially this is like a
like a vision um
uh and language model, right?
And so, the key idea um that
a lot of the generous robot policy works
built upon is that you can view robotics
as a similar multi-model sequencing
modeling problem, right?
Where you're trying to learn a powerful
model that maps from images and text um
to answers, right? But in robotics, in
our case,
the answers are not really text, right?
But they will represent actions.
Um
And [clears throat]
this has many benefits because um now
because we have now language tokens,
image tokens, and action tokens,
we can leverage also many of the
advances that have been made
in NLP and vision
in like general like multi-model
sequence modeling.
So, for from non-robotic domains into
the robotic
domain.
Um
So, as a first step towards developing
such generous robot policies,
we developed Octo, which was the kind of
the first open-source generous policy.
And this is
in a nutshell a large transformer-based
policy that was trained on 800,000
robot trajectories of the Open X
Embodiment data set
I just talked about.
>> [snorts]
>> Um and here,
similar to in the
similar to the Gato paper that Scott
Reed talked about
last week,
the the main idea is that you tokenize
all this diverse heterogeneous input
and action outputs and train this large
transformer, right?
Um So, how does it work?
So, Octo is a fairly straightforward
transformer model.
So, it has a pre-trained language
encoder that tokenizes your
language inputs.
>> [snorts]
>> Um
Uh we used a T5 model here. Uh and then
it has a
observation tokenizer
that patches files your image
observations and runs them
[clears throat] through a shallow CNN to
produce your
image tokens.
So
then you concatenate both tokens,
observation and task tokens,
and
pass them through a transformer
that in essence
looks very similar
to a vanilla vision transformer like a
VIT.
Um and
>> [clears throat]
>> maybe one thing to note here is that the
transformer
in Octo is has a block-wise causal
structure.
So all the task tokens cannot attend to
each other,
but they can't look at the observation
tokens.
And
>> [clears throat]
>> observation tokens from the first
time steps can look at themselves and
the tasks, but not at future time steps.
>> [snorts]
>> All right. And then
for the actions, we define these purple
readout tokens,
which are essentially placeholder tokens
that summarize the embeddings
that then go into these functional
heads.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> One thing to note is that
this model we train it with goal
condition behavior cloning. So this
means that um
it predicts a sequence of actions
to reach a goal state given the current
state. And as we see as we saw also
previously, this is a very flexible
formulation
because it allows you to um
your goal states uh in various ways, uh
be it um
uh goal images or natural language
instructions.
All right. So, we have now the task
observations and the readout blocks. And
then, uh because this is a sequential
model, um you pass this um this this you
run this over multiple time steps.
And
in our [clears throat] case, the uh
functional um heads uh
uh were diffusion decoding heads
uh because we found also in in
experiments that it really helps um
handle multimodal behavior uh much
better than than other ways.
Um
and
I also wanted to um talk about some key
design decisions um that we made in this
uh
in this project. Um first of all, uh we
tried to invest all our compute inside
the transformer um
as [clears throat] opposed to prior
designs that
um had like these
larger ResNet style encoders for each
image separately and then uh merge them
uh in a late fusion style. Um
originally, we thought that wow, we have
like so much data, we can just train
everything from from scratch. Um and
maybe in hindsight, it was not the best
idea, but at the time, like that's what
we thought.
Um and maybe some additional insights we
had in this project was that although we
didn't align the coordinate frames from
all these different uh data sets, which
kind of was a scalability choice,
uh we did take care of aligning the
gripper dimension of all the different
data sets.
Um this was because in the beginning, um
a lot of the failures were uh related to
the gripper, like early grasping.
>> [clears throat]
>> So, we kind of then made sure that the
semantics uh for the gripper
uh were all the same. So, like one for
opening and zero for closing. And here
in the figure, you can see like some of
the different options that different
data sets had
had applied
for
controlling their
end effector
gripper action. Right? So, it could be
like absolute, relative, continuous, and
so forth. And so, that's the one thing
we kind of um
uh
tried to align across all data sets.
All right. [clears throat] So, we
divided the evaluation into zero-shot
evals and fine-tuning evals
across many kind of
labs and institutions.
And we used the same fine-tuning recipe
to adapt Octo to new sensory and action
spaces.
I won't go too much into the results,
but in general, we found that Octo could
control multiple robot embodiments out
of the box
and also outperformed previous models
from Google
trained on similar data.
So, particularly like the RT1X model
that was trained for the Open X
Embodiment project. It outperformed this
model and it also matched the RT2X,
which was a much larger 55 billion
parameter
closed-source VLA model from Google,
which was kind of like the first VLA.
>> [snorts]
>> All right. Um
This video shows I think the first
successful grasp we ever saw from our
Octo model on the Google robot.
Which we were serving via remote server.
>> Bam!
>> Woo!
>> One success. Nice.
>> Very nice.
>> One success.
>> All right, good to
>> Yeah.
Um by the way, on the left this is Quan.
Uh this is our guest uh lecturer today.
Uh at the time he was at Google.
Um so he was helping us um do this uh
um our evaluations.
So um
Yeah, it's also worth uh it was very
cool um
>> [clears throat]
>> cuz robot evals are always very
challenging and even more when you are
not next to the robot, but you have to
rely on people helping you.
Um and uh
one thing to note here is that actually
um
these evals uh
um in Mountain View they were quite out
of distribution for our model because
um although [clears throat]
um we had trained on their data, like
the data that Google had collected, um
that data had been collected in a
different building. So they had moved
buildings, uh which is, you know,
obviously like then quite out of out of
distribution. Um
>> [clears throat]
>> uh and so we were excited that, you
know, even like, you know, simple tasks
were still working.
Um so this was our Eureka moment.
Okay, so this were zero-shot
evaluations, um but one thing I want to
highlight about generalist robot
policies in general is the adaptability
aspect because
ideally these models should be useful uh
for your robot even if the model did not
pre-train on your model. Right? Like it
should be like uh a good basis for um
post-training it to your particular
embodiment because
like it could be a new robot or maybe
for this particular task um you want to
add some new sensing modalities. Maybe
you need to do a um force torque uh
sensing or you want to change the number
of cameras uh for your particular task,
right? Uh or maybe you want to do
different um like action uh spaces.
Maybe now instead of
like
Cartesian control, you want to do like
joint control,
right?
So,
um
how we did approach this in Octo is that
uh once you have a new input, like let's
say force torque readings, you can slot
in this new
input
with a few tokens, and then you
fine-tune the model. And because um in
this case, most of the parameters were
inside the transformer itself,
you get to retain most of the knowledge
when when fine-tuning.
Um
and um
yeah, I won't go into detail about the
fine-tuning results, but basically what
we found out when we were doing this
experiments for different fine-tuning
setups across different labs,
was that um
fine-tuning
from a generalist robot policy or robot
foundation model RFM,
uh
worked much better than any other like
state-of-the-art visual representation
uh learning-based backbone.
So, this is kind of like the key
message, I think. And I think this
applies also to
many other current like state-of-the-art
um
uh models.
And
we actually, I think in terms of the
adoption, we
it got quite popular, and we actually
saw
we found [clears throat]
that people or researchers across the
world actually
used Octo and fine-tuned fine-tuned
fine-tuned it
to their embodiment. So, here is like on
the left a video I found it on Twitter
uh from a researcher who fine-tuned it
uh on an unseen
uh spot robot.
And then also
uh on the right you can see like a
Japanese company that
used
used it to find unit for their humanoid
robot.
All right.
So so far
we have talked about how you can train a
generalist or policy from scratch
on
you know on a diverse data set
containing a bunch of single arm
manipulation tasks, right?
But ideally like
we want to expand this to multiple
embodiments, right? Because how
generalist is this really like if all it
can do is just like control like a 7° of
freedom arm, right? Like ideally it
should work no matter
what robot embodiment you have, right?
And this is like I think really
important because as you all know um
this is also one of the cool things of
robotics that they are all these
different embodiments, right? Tailored
for different tasks, right? So we have
drones that can fly around, we have
quadrupeds,
we have self-driving cars, humanoids,
etc. So
what I'm trying to say is that if we
develop methods that can
learn from all these different
embodiments,
then like we can scale also the data
that we can
consume, right?
Like there are there is more data than
we think out there for robotics, but we
all it's kind of like challenge because
of its heterogeneity to
have methods that can like transfer the
relevant bits and knowledge is
across all these embodiments.
Right. So
you can imagine [clears throat] for
example that
like navigation data could transfer
a behavior to drones by learning how to
avoid obstacles for example because it's
kind of a common behavior no matter if
it's like a
like a navigation robot like a Roomba or
if it's a
an indoor drone for example, right?
>> [snorts]
>> Um and so ideally we would like to have
a very scalable approach that can learn
from any robot embodiment without any
constraints,
no manual like action space alignments
or
any kind of like yeah, constraints,
right? We just want to like take our
data
pass it through our transformer and like
have have the model figure out like how
to combine all these things.
Um and that's
kind of what we did in this paper called
CrossFormer
where we added more embodiments such as
by manual manipulation, navigation
or locomotion to the data mix we
originally had trained Octo on for a
total of 900,000
robot trajectories
and trained a big transformer but now
with embodiment specific heads
on it.
So we had like one head for like
controlling single arms,
one for quadrupeds and so forth.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> so this model accepts variable
observation inputs and predict the
variable
action outputs which is quite important
in order to predict action chunks of
different length
because
basically one of the challenges when you
do this kind of extreme cross embodiment
learning is that
a lot of these embodiments have vastly
different control frequencies, right? So
it could be from like you know, like a
Widow X is doing like 5 hertz control
to like a bimanual dexterous
manipulation robot that is doing like 50
hertz control, right?
And so this means also the action chunk
length that your model should predict is
like vastly different.
>> [clears throat]
>> So having these different heads is like
one way how you can go
uh, about this.
Um, and yeah.
Um,
this way also you don't have to do any
action space alignment.
Um, and
uh, in order to
uh, maximize transfer across
embodiments, um,
you try to maximize parameter sharing
across embodiments. So for example, um,
by sharing image encoders
uh, weights for camera views of the same
type.
Um,
yeah.
And uh, here are rollouts from the
cross-former model. Um,
as you can see uh,
like there the evaluations is like very
very diverse. Uh, many different
embodiments from uh,
the uh, quadraped in the center um,
to
um, like the single arm manipulation
with the Franka arms. Um,
we [clears throat] have also have like
outdoor and indoor navigation.
And um,
yeah, also like the the sushi cutting
task that I already presented. We did it
uh, here too, which is this like by
manual
uh, dexterous super long horizon um,
task.
And so,
uh, what I want to highlight here is
that um,
all rollouts that you see, all video
snippets that you see were produced by
this by the same model. It's like a
single checkpoint that's controlling all
this um,
robot embodiments. Right? So it's not
like we cherry-picked like oh, like this
this this checkpoint works best for this
robot, so let's do that. It's like all
the same set of um, neural network
weights.
Uh,
so I think that's pretty cool.
And um, regarding quantitative results,
um, we also found that this kind of
cross-embodied policy uh
model matched
or outperformed kind of specialist
policies that were uh tailored
um for specific embodiments.
All right. So, CrossFormer tried to
answer if a generalist policy could
control multiple embodiments and
outperform embodiment-specific
specialist policies.
Now, this work from TRI, on the other
hand, tried to answer the question um
does multitask pretraining help post
training?
This is kind of something that many in
the community believe to be true, right?
Um
but in robotics, determining this is
somewhat like not trivial.
Um so, I recommend this reading this
paper because they did a very rigorous
study um and evaluate
by evaluating this uh kind of diffusion
transformer policies on around that were
trained on around a thousand uh 1,700
hours of pretraining data including the
OXE
uh data sets. And then, they fine-tuned
it into a um
uh
single by manual uh tasks on their
Frankas
uh across both Sim and Eval.
Um and so, they really went
out of their way to kind of gain
statistical significance um here
uh by doing blind AB testing in the real
world with the operators. So, the
operators
like would not know which policy they
were scoring at the time and so forth.
Right? And you can see like really
impressive dexterous tasks like with
like cutting this this apple um
>> [clears throat and cough]
>> which is like super long horizon. I
think it goes like for 2 minutes or
something. Uh very, very impressive.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> and
I want to highlight like a few key
results here that they did. Um
so [clears throat]
uh they found out that yes, indeed, like
pre-training
>> [clears throat]
>> Sorry. Helps and makes uh uh
post-training to single tasks um up to
three times or five times more um sample
efficient.
And that this is uh most beneficial at
uh low post-training data regime. So, if
you don't have a lot of data to
fine-tune to a new task, then uh this is
where you reap most of these benefits.
Um but interestingly, um I think they
also found that
um things like how you normalize your
data uh often impacted uh downstream
performance much more than architectural
or algorithmic changes.
Um which again shows also like uh why
robot learning is like also like so
challenging cuz there there are like
kind of so many different knobs that one
can uh tune to uh improve performance,
right? And yeah, sometimes even
things so simple as the normalization um
like is is really, really important.
Okay.
>> [clears throat]
>> So, everything we have covered um so far
today uh has been pretty much focused on
training generalist robot policies uh
from scratch
uh on robot data.
Um but even as I said before, even if at
the time, you know, um
people thought like, "Oh, this is like a
lot of data, like um
uh when we're doing Octo and so forth."
Um the truth is that this still is uh
kind of um like ORC-E um data set is is
minuscule uh compared to LLMs uh and
VLMs that are trained on much, much more
data, right? So, the obviously the
obvious question here to ask um
by many is does internet-scale uh priors
or do internet scale priors like VLMs
also transfer to downstream robotics
control?
And how would we go about that, right?
And so the first idea
to explore how to do this are similar to
the Lava architecture
we saw a few weeks ago. If you recall
here, the idea here this was like how to
add
vision to an LLM, right? This is at the
context where we saw this when we're
discussing VLMs. And here the idea was
to prepend image tokens to the text so
that the LLM then runs standard
self-attention over this unified
sequence so that image tokens and text
tokens are together
without any modifications like to the
attention
mechanism or and so forth, right?
And so
the key question people ask is like,
well, can we treat now robot actions the
same way as we as Lava treats like image
tokens for
adding this into the LLM, right?
Um
And that's basically how the first VLMs
got fine-tuned into VLAs.
Right? So you have now this VLM
architecture and what you do is you
tokenize your robot actions and inject
these into your LLM vocabulary.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> and one common approach how to do this
is
that you can override like the last
frequent tokens in your vocabulary um
with [clears throat] these new action
tokens.
And now your LLM can predict these new
action tokens as part
because it's part of its vocabulary and
then you
train this with next token prediction
with the same cross-entropy loss.
Um we already covered action
tokenization uh, in the past lecture so
I won't go into details again, but just
recap, um, the first approaches
um, like RT2 or OpenVLA,
uh, used a very simple naive, um, per
dimension, per time step uh, binning
discretization, uh, approach.
Okay, so this is kind of the high-level
idea, um, but as as I said before, as
some of you will, um, kind of train like
yourself VLM, uh, VLAs for
uh, your group projects, um, I thought
it might be good to share a few tips and
tricks,
uh, about how you might, uh, go about
training them, right? Uh, and some
questions that, uh, might arise, uh,
when doing so. But I think like this a
lot of these are also general to, um,
other models that are not um,
specially, uh, VLAs, but could also be
for your world model or, um,
other sort of like large-scale, uh,
robot policy training.
Um,
so if you, um, look for example at this,
um, kind of first, uh, VLAs, um, the
first question could be, uh, when you,
let's say you start, I don't know,
training OpenVLA or something on your
robot, um, is how do I know if my model
has converged
uh, when when training. Uh, and so for
auto regressive VLAs, uh, we found a
good a good rule of thumb um, is, um, to
wait until your action token accuracy
reaches around 95%.
Um, so one thing to note here is that,
um, this action token accuracy is
computed on teacher forcing,
uh, and does not represent like the
actual performance in real world
rollouts,
um, but basically, like before it
reaches 95%,
uh, you probably should not do any real
world rollouts,
uh, cuz they won't be very good.
Um, um, so this measures like, um, if we
picked kind of the exact action been
correctly and this like discretize uh
approach.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> but then you typically also will want to
track let's say um the L1 and L2 action
errors
uh which measure how far off the
predicted uh continuous so how far the
predicted continuous actions are from
the ground truth. Um so this means like
once you have um detokenized uh your uh
action tokens and unnormalized system uh
back to continuous values, you can
compare them with your ground truth
actions
uh and see uh how how well you're doing.
Um another uh design choice one has to
make uh when training generalist
policies is how to batch heterogeneous
data.
This will be maybe less relevant for you
because I assume you all we all will
mostly be like fine-tuning on like your
one robot.
But when you do pre-training, this is
kind of a more relevant like with more
different embodiment sources, this
becomes a more relevant question. Um
because you might have as I said before,
let's say one embodiment with a single
third-person camera uh observation input
and another one um where for example,
you add two wrist cameras so for a total
of three.
Um and now therefore you can't just
simply stack these into a batch. So the
easiest way to handle this heterogeneity
is of course um that you can pad to the
longest number of the observation inputs
and mask the attention appropriately.
Um and this is for example uh what we
did for OCTO and CrossFormer.
Um and so this is very easy to
implement, right? It's probably like the
first thing one uh
can start with.
However, you also um need to uh
understand the trade-offs you're making
here if you have very heterogeneous
observations.
Um because uh like
now this can result in half your batch
being full of zeros. Right? So, um like
you will be wasting like a lot of flops
because like like if you're padding all
the time, then like yeah, it's a lot of
zeros um
uh you're pushing through your GPU.
Um another different way how you could
implement this in your data loading
pipeline is to use sequence packing, um
which is kind of a technique
specifically tailored to
um handle variable-length inputs with
transformers. Um so, the key idea is
that instead of padding
um and waste this compute on zeros, you
concatenate everything into a single
long vector
um so that you maximize your GPU
throughput. Um and so, now here every um
sample uh uh contributes exactly the
tokens that it actually has.
Um
and uh in order to keep track uh of
where each sample um in this long vector
starts and ends, um
you will have to maintain like um kind
of like a um
this cumulative sequence length uh
uh like variable.
>> [clears throat]
>> The
um trade-off that you're making when you
apply um when you use the sequence
packing approach is kind of
implementation complexity.
Uh so, you'll need um block diagonal
attention masks um
so that [clears throat] tokens from
different samples don't attend to each
other.
And uh also, you will need to reset your
positional encodings um
um at each uh sample boundary, uh which
I visualize here. Um these kind of two
concrete implementation uh
challenges [clears throat] I just
mentioned.
Um so, you have to be very careful um on
which tokens are allowed to attend uh uh
to which tokens.
Uh so, like the tokens in each sample
should only attend to to their own
tokens,
right? And then, like, be careful to
reset um your uh positional
uh encodings um at every uh sample
boundary, so you don't kind of
uh uh keep growing the the length of
this.
Um
Now, also, let's talk about a practical
um but often overlooked topic. Uh, how
do you actually load data uh during
training? Uh, cuz this matters actually
more than you might think.
Um so, there are kind of two main
strategies. Um on the left, uh you can
see um
uh sequential reads with a shuffle
buffer. Um this is what uh
like, for example, we use for Octo or
OpenVLA also uses.
Um so, you um stream data sequentially
from shards into into a buffer, and then
you sample um a batch from there.
And um kind of the key inside here is
that
if your buffer if your shuffle buffer is
too small, um your um
>> [clears throat and cough]
>> your batches uh might become correlated.
Um as the degree of freedom um sorry, as
as the degree of randomness is
uh directly proportional to the size uh
of your shuffle buffer. Um and so, this
is, for example, some This is, for
example, something we learned um the
hard way
uh when we started training Octo. Um so,
in the beginning, uh we had a shuffle
buffer of only uh 20,000 samples.
Um and um combined with
uh trajectory-level interleaving, this
resulted in really poor um like,
generalization performance.
Um um
and so, we solved this by um
uh shuffling and interleaving from
different trajectories uh uh sorry
sorry, by uh shuffling and interleaving
frames from different trajectories uh
before decoding uh the images um and uh
this allowed us to grow our shuffle
buffer
up to
500,000
samples. And this was kind of like
actually made a big impact in the
performance of the model.
So nothing else changed. It was the same
like
like data mixture and and everything.
But this was quite important.
And on the right you have you can you
see like
>> [clears throat and cough]
>> you can also implement
a data loading solution based on true
random reads
where you maintain a flat index over
your data set
and perform like random seeks to to
build build each
build each batch. And
this will gives you kind of this will
give you more exact unbiased randomness,
but
here having like fast IO will be very
important because you know you can't
typically like load
all like your data set into into memory.
And
yeah, so basically
um
there's there's kind of this trade-off,
right? And
there are solutions that try to combine
best of both worlds. You can also
like do like kind of chunk random reads
instead of like loading just like images
or something.
But
yeah, this
like data loading once you start doing
pre-training for kind of heterogeneous
large data sets
is becomes really also like key
like a key architectural choice that
will affect all that will affect also
the performance of your
policy like
via for example randomness and so forth.
Another practical question that comes up
um
when you're training general policies
is
how do you handle the fact that
different robots have different action
spaces?
Right? So, maybe like one data set with
one embodiment has like seven degrees of
freedom arm.
In the next data set, you have like like
by manual with 14 degrees of freedom.
And so,
there are kind of like two different
approaches um
that are more or less popular. Um one on
the left is kind of the transformer
style approach,
where you have a shared transformer
backbone
that processes the observations and then
routes this to
separate embodiment specific action
heads.
Um which with the benefit that you can
easily have variable length outputs to
accommodate for the different control
frequencies.
Um but of course, the downside is that
if you want to add a new embodiment, now
you will need to add a new head
and find your this probably.
Um and on the right, you can see the
kind of more Pi Zero style approach,
where you still have a shared
transformer backbone, but now
this is followed by a single action
expert that outputs into a kind of
unified padded
action space.
And so here,
what you do is you
will typically pick the the maximum
action dimension
across all your embodiments and
have [clears throat] every robot action
zero pad to fit that.
And so this is
kind of more more simple, much more
simple architecturally.
>> [cough]
[clears throat]
>> Um
though
Yeah, here like maybe like one caveat
would be that you will typically predict
a single
like a
fixed length action chunk for all
regardless of their control frequency.
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah, maybe
I have a question for you now.
How do you think that the VLA
for both of these options will know then
the model
which embodiment it should produce
actions for at test time?
So maybe you can take
20 seconds to discuss with your
neighbor.
So the question is how does the model
know at test time?
Like if it's should produce actions
let's say for a 7° of freedom
arm or a 14° of freedom arm.
And we have these two models with
one model has
embodiment specific heads and the other
one is a single action expert expert
with this padding.
Where all embodiments get uh
predicted.
>> [clears throat]
>> So the question is like at test time you
have one model
and now
you need to do inference like
like how how how does it work? Like what
do you do?
Okay, so for the let's start with the
cross former. How does it work for the
multiple heads?
Like does the model infer like which
head you are controlling or do you need
to tell and specify to the model?
Yeah?
Yeah.
Yeah, so that's that's a good guess.
So it's kind of a mixture of all your
responses.
So [clears throat] for the
cross former style approach,
this is explicitly handled by the user.
All right, so like you will specify
which head to use as part of your prompt
or configuration.
So you're kind of telling it like all
used the bimanual head or used the
quadruped head and so forth. Right? So
the routing is hard coded by the user.
And the Pi zero style
like single action expert approach,
there's typically no explicit head
selection.
And so the model has to infer
the embodiment implicitly from the
observations itself. Right? And
[clears throat] so this is like the
camera views. Right? So different types
of camera views give some information on
like which embodiment this might be.
Also the proprioceptive is also
an input
to the action head. So this will also
give a very very strong hint on like
what embodiment it should produce
actions for.
And often also the language instructions
too actually. Right? Because like like
you cannot do the same tasks with all
embodiments. Right? So
like yeah, if you tell like I don't know
like a a Roomba like cut the sushi like
you know, it's probably not going to
work. Right? So
all these together give give like a
strong hint to the model on like what
embodiment it should be controlling.
Um
And [clears throat] so yeah, like the
backbone should learn how to pick up on
these cues and then
route information accordingly home
through the action expert.
All right.
So [clears throat] to close off the kind
of this VLA part, I want to present
some of the high level ideas
on how a lot of the current
state-of-the-art VLAs are being trained,
>> [clears throat]
>> mostly based on the Pi 05 and the
knowledge insulation papers.
Um, there like of course like some
follow-ups and
I don't want to um, kind of explain
everything since like I think later Quan
will also share more about the latest
model.
Uh, but I would say this is kind of like
a pretty solid recipe that nowadays
a lot of like different
labs have
adopted or found success in replicating.
Um, and so
first here the VLM backbone is
trained with next token prediction
on a mixture of
fast tokenized robot actions and web
data.
Um, so co-training on web data helps to
preserve
um, kind of the capabilities of the VLM
backbone and like
avoids like catastrophic forgetting.
Um,
and the fast tokens
are good for representation learning,
too.
And we already covered a few lectures
ago how fast tokenization works.
Uh, if you remember.
Um, and then
in the sec- the second part is the
the action expert
which is trained with like a flow
matching head, right? This is like the
single action expert that will
predict
like all the different embodiments.
Um, so now you produce this continuous
actions with the flow matching head.
And
besides
uh,
uh, not attending to the fast tokens,
the action action expert also implements
a stop gradient operation.
So this means that the action
expert reads from the VLM backbone, but
can't update it,
insulating it
in order to preserve its VLM
kind of like semantic capabilities.
And this also helps
like convergence, like fast training,
and so forth. And you can find more
details on
the knowledge installation paper from
Danny Drees on the bottom right.
All right. So far we have talked about
data and the modeling side of generalist
from policies.
Last but not least,
we'll also need to talk a little bit
about evaluations
because as I said before,
this now it's getting very very
expensive, right?
And
>> [clears throat]
>> Has anyone of you already done any
rollouts with your SO101?
I don't know. Yes?
Yeah?
Did you like it?
>> I mean,
not all
>> Did it Did it work?
>> Yeah, this morning the last one.
>> Okay, awesome.
Okay.
Um so, good. So, now when you keep doing
this for a month, maybe like when I ask
you in a month you'll be like, oh, I
can't see this robot anymore. It's like
so expensive, like so tiring to do like
rollouts with it.
Um because
like
there are like several things that are
make it difficult, right? So,
for example, if you have like a
third-person camera mounted to your
robot,
and you train like you collect some
data, train your policy on it,
and then someone goes and bumps into the
camera, and now your camera is in a
different like pose or position. Maybe
like you didn't cali- I don't know,
like, you know, like it will be like out
of distribution, like it doesn't work
anymore. Maybe you have to like collect
new data, find tune, I don't know.
Um then also hardware failures. Um
I think I saw some some people already
had hardware failures. How many people
had hardware failures?
Oh my god.
All right. Lots of hardware failures.
So, that's another thing like maybe you
collect some data, right? Um and let's
say your policy has proprioceptive
input, right? Um
and now
you have to do some surgery to save your
robot. You know, you put like new motors
or something. Uh
and now like your proprioception will be
how will have different readings than
the data that you collected and trained
your policy on, right? So, there are
like a lot of things that, you know,
could go wrong. Like I'm sure they will
be fantastic and
uh you will all enjoy it doing evals.
Um but yeah. And in general, it also
like takes a a long time to do evals,
right? Like
like you know,
it's like
low frequency uh control. It's not very
fast. It takes like a long time. You see
like move it and like, "Okay, move
another centimeter." And you know, like
you wait there for 2 minutes to see like
if it grasp something or not.
So, it just takes a long time.
And
so, one way around this um is to use
simulation uh because
>> [clears throat and cough]
>> simulation makes research more
accessible uh to people who might not
have your uh same robot set up
on one hand. And also it makes it a bit
more reproducible because now you don't
have to like, I don't know, um you know,
this risk of like bumping into cameras
or your proprioception to have different
readings and so forth.
And um this is why during the
development of Octo, um we started a
parallel project which we coined uh
Simpler.
Um this is actually this was a
collaboration actually with um both Quan
and uh also Ted Xiao, who also gave a
guest lecture uh, a few weeks ago. So,
they were both at Google at the time.
Um,
>> [cough]
>> and so, [clears throat] in this project,
we uh, try to leverage Sim2Real um,
for policies trained exclusively on
real-world data. Um, and so, the hope
here is really that if we can find a way
to evaluate our real-world policies in
simulation in a way that informs us
about how they will perform in the uh,
real world, then uh, we can just like,
you know, sit back and enjoy life and
um,
uh, while we run a large number of evals
in simulation.
Um, and
Okay. So,
uh, I will ver- on a very high level
explain how the idea of this works.
Um, so, the success rates in Sim2Real
are correlated um, between um,
simulation and real world, so that's
great. Uh, and this holds for different
models. Um, some from Google's, um, also
the Octo.
And importantly, this also holds for
different um,
distribution shifts.
Uh, like textures, um, different camera
poses and distractors.
>> [clears throat]
>> So, how does it work? So, the first step
is um, um, that you need to mitigate the
control gap between um, the simulated
and the real-world environments
um, in order to ensure that um, the
policies uh, actions executed in
simulation will yield the same result
uh, um,
uh, compared to the real robot's end
effector
uh, when observed
um, when executed on the real world.
Um, and so, in order to do this um,
like, you can do this by doing a a
system identification procedure uh, on a
small uh, number of samples collected
uh, from the real on the real world.
Right? Um, so, basically,
um, this means like your
in a nutshell, your low-level controller
in the real world and in the simulation
should produce like the same outputs,
more or less.
Um
And now, the second step is to minimize
the visual distribution shift.
Um by trying to match the simulated
visuals to those of the real world. Um
here we did a very simple procedure.
This is not like super realistic, like
uh like you know, like Nvidia Isaac Lab
um kind of style.
Uh here we did a green screening as a
first step um to try to minimize this
visual distribution shift. Um so, this
[clears throat] means we uh segmented
out interactive simulated assets and
overlayed them into uh real-world
backgrounds. And then, the second one is
texture matching, where uh we projected
um uh textures from real-world objects
uh into simulation assets. Like, for
example, the Coke can. Like, we take the
texture of like a real-world Coke can
and overlay it on top of like the
simulated Coke can.
Um and so,
maybe one thing to notice how like what
you get out of this is um so, simpler
gives you correlated um
uh
um performance. So,
it does not mean that so,
um it does not mean that if in
simulation [snorts]
uh you get 50% success rate on picking
[clears throat] up the Coke can, that in
the real world you will get also si- 55
uh success rate. So, it's not absolute.
It doesn't tell you anything about the
absolute um rollout success rate
performance of your robot in the real
world.
All it can do is give you pairwise
comparison. So, if policy A uh performs
uh better than policy B in this simpler
framework, um this will also hold true
um in the real world.
Um and the paper also has like kind of
more explanations on how you can measure
this with like ranking and so on.
Um so I invite you to check it out.
Um
there is uh
some follow-up work um uh cool work um
that tries to improve like correlations
of such real-to-sim evaluation
frameworks
uh such as Polaris, uh Robot Arena
Infinity,
uh or RoboLab.
Uh and maybe there are some some others
that I I'm not aware of.
Um and so I think this is uh um really
interesting um
to enable
uh like researchers and practitioners
around the world um to do like research
on generalist robot policies. So, uh it
abstracts away to some degree the need
of you having to have like all these
different robot setups um to try to see
if your generalist robot policy
uh is actually generalist.
All right. Uh so, to conclude today's
lecture, um
>> [clears throat]
>> we talked about the three ingredients um
that we have covered in order to uh
develop generalist robot policies.
Uh we have talked about how you can
aggregate existing offline robot data
and convert it into a common format um
that enables co-training on them.
Uh then we have covered how you can uh
train generalist policies and
cross-embodiment cross-embodiment
generalist robot policies
uh from scratch on this data
uh followed by how [snorts] um to
leverage internet-scale priors like VLMs
uh in order to train uh VLAs or
vision-language-action models.
And finally, we have uh also shown one
way um the community is exploring uh for
how to make uh evaluations of such
generalist robot policies
uh more scalable uh by leveraging
correlated evaluations in simulation.
And uh with this, thank you for
attention.